[Music]
guys
let me just say something really quick
bianca
wanted me to keep secrets from no i
didn't shut up
i let's this is the podcast
etc i would like to i don't know what
the opposite of a shout out is
but i would like to give a i'd like to
send a shame spiral
to my immune system because the most
i've gone out
in 14 months and i [ __ ] around and got
a cold
you can hear it and and
so shame shame on you immune system i
look i love you
you're my brother but you really
disappointed me and
my point is bianca wanted me to not tell
you guys i was sick she wanted to keep
secrets
no i didn't i just it doesn't matter
what what were you getting at no i want
you to like
remind them you have like the vaccine oh
of course i have a vaccine yeah but it's
oh yeah i'm not saying it like you're
making it sound like i'm like
i can't i can't [ __ ] believe i got a
cold like
i didn't even know you could this is for
cold awareness as much as anything okay
that i still that guys
it's still out there colds are real even
if you have the vaccine
and um it's just a real
it's one of them things then i got a
cold and now
and now you're gonna be mad at me for
two hours no i'm not
because of our beginning i realize that
most people don't hold a grudge as long
as i do
yeah i was like that's just your
projection as usual
i'll hold a grudge decade minimum
minimum i sound like voice to men right
now the the guy the talking part
girl um
oh yeah all right so we got something we
got four new songs that will didn't set
up
[Music]
uh one of them is let called let neil
clear his throat i believe
doesn't feel spiritually aligned with
this show
no it feels like it belongs on like a
morning zoo cruise yeah
wacky uh thank you for your time
that's probably five different tracks on
garageband there
i like letting maybe let him maybe just
take let him
dude let him that's even okay
i mean the rattlesnake is kind of what
it i don't know it doesn't work
but i would like to say i'm trying to
solve this this is a story
that i don't think i've ever told okay
you know how people will try to give
people like me demos and [ __ ] yeah
somebody gave rock chris
let me clear my throat the demo and he
gave it to rick rubin and that's how it
became a hit
let me clear them up gave it to him like
yo
play and i don't know how why he
listened to that one
that's so but it's never works ever
except that time does that guy get
credit
i believe it's fat man scoop or somebody
i think it's
like when he was just right the guy got
all everything
um that's so cool
cool uh yeah dj cool gave it to chris
and then i don't know if that's in the
wikipedia page
but it was used in the 2019-2020
season of the buffalo sabres
um the cornhuskers use it to pump up the
crowd
over there in nebraska no mention of
chris
um yeah so uh that's a real
what neil sentence that he just read is
straight off the wikipedia that's off
the wikipedia page
that's not off the dome as it were
um being very 90s so
yeah anyhow um
so let's now we're doing songs i guess
let's do songs we come on yeah we got a
bunch of songs
same gentlemen plant medicine
plant that's called plant medicine i
can't always understand it yeah damn man
yeah he's mixed the vocals
and that doesn't spirit padre
gets at something plant medicine sounds
like some jamboree [ __ ] it sounds like
like we're going to do some plant
matters and round up some
corn huskers yeah hit it
i got something to show you
that's a song called i got something to
chepel you but
the problem is you guys you heard it
it's three four seconds before we
you gotta keep it short guys don't be
like us
who do a two and a half hour podcast no
that's our right
i got something to tell you no it also
sounds like you got will to do the
vocals
yeah that's like
maybe you're um maybe it's the volume's
too high i don't know i don't like the
sounds of all these
i don't either but i don't but that may
be just a music problem
all right what and we have a fourth song
no one cares
oh that's a guy i like that one that one
that's not bad that's usable
that's a guy who um was castrated
his when he's telling a story and his
girlfriend doesn't care
she sings that to him oh that's right
and then he recorded it for us
so that's usable that's andre williams
and that's
also short yep gets the point
usable
um my father gave me a name
you know what i'm talking about uh okay
so anyhow how was your week
[ __ ] great well great great great
great because i need help guys because i
have a cold today yeah so
i'm a little grogged up ooh maybe i
might be reading more
oh i'm not that sick don't be crazy how
was your week
um okay
i was did i do my birthday
well we talked we pre-taped we
appreciate it to accommodate your
birthday
birthday what was it i had a pool party
and a barbecue
and i did it right in like outside of
la i just got airbnb got it and then
i invited you but you must have lost
something
no i asked you and you're like
immune system um and i had a
pinata that was me great
um and you didn't have people hit you
with a bat you had them kiss you
correct kiss me and you'll get this
sweet sweet duel says
did you what'd you do a bat yeah and
then i put um
well i went to the the pinata mart and
they i was like um uh tiene una mos
negra
mas negra like you know wanted to look
at me they were like no more black
no yeah so i put a lot of
bronzer she was in blackface
but the point was still there she had my
same curl pattern did uh
did the police come and shut you down
for black pinata um
and then yeah so i did my birthday hey
oh and then i did the um
yeah i don't know it was nice it was
great i didn't think about much
everyone's drinking have a good time and
then it was done
great beautiful i did did you
do girls what did girls want on their
birthday well i did on the invite say
in the what to bring section i wrote
gift gifts i was like bring a gift
it could be anything though i reminded
everyone like you can even draw me a
picture but i'm saying like
do you want guys clearly want to get
laid
like that's all guys want okay anyway i
like
things so even a a drawing
or just a i thought of you and i you
know
a flower a nice rock a shell
or more can we get into what the best
gift and what the worst gift was
um let's see what i got i got a nice
framed
picture i got ma i love magic of me
what was it of neil itching his throat
what was it um i got a magnet of myself
which i love
magnets i love i have some good news for
you for some reason i just found eight
magnets under my chair
oh my god i've been playing with eight
magnets
i love these kind of magnets too
sweetheart
oh my god i literally just found i was
playing i don't know how they got i mean
i know how they got there
how did they get there uh my phone
yeah this is amazing i love these and i
always see them on people's fridge i'm
like i need those
if only someday i'll get one of those
did you plan this
i hadn't no i could i literally couldn't
have planned it
how could i planned it bianca me and
will
got together beforehand i was like hey
do you know anything that bianca really
likes but doesn't
yeah it's funny she always brings up
magnets
um but yeah no i got well i just you
just got through seven magnets right i
got seven presents today
uh i got what i get i got very nice
things i don't remember right now
because you're excited
but lovely thank you for all the gifts
and um thanks for the laughs so it was
great
it was fine what did you do while i was
celebrating my birthday
i really remember all i do now is
[ __ ]
work on the documentary i know which may
or may not story but
work on the documentary and is it
getting you down
no it's not getting me down it's just
hard and
kind of endless and like not fun
uh just do that and then i'm working on
the show the new york show
so that's kind of all i did and then i i
got i went out
once and got cold what's up you get cold
like when we
flew to dc you got sick on a plane
for like two hours that's
that's not that's happening like you
just got like
red and itchy well i just get air sick
i get like nauseous on the plane like i
get
i get not i have to almost sleep to
like get through the nausea really yeah
how do do you get sick often like how
many times a year
uh once okay yeah
i but nauseous i get nauseous pretty
easily
that's awful yeah so when people bring
up nausea with um
ayahuasca i'm like oh you're like just
another i used to
at one point i was taking zoloft but uh
i like had doubled my dosage and i would
throw up
probably four nights a week around
sunset
around sunset just sundown i
just would throw up i would just get
nauseous and throw up and i thought
this is what an idiot i am i didn't put
it together i thought it was
i was eating a lot of lifesavers so i
was like you know these lifesavers are
making me vomit
so i had to like stop they had they when
they introduced the sugar freeze i
didn't go
i went ham so i don't i
nausea to me is just like yeah just
throw up and then you're dead that's so
weird
it's not like oh my god my body's
heaving
so uh that was my week nothing of much
interesting
now so let's uh let's do with a recap
okay go of the news
went a step further and just dropped out
of the french open
yeah which is wild right and mentioned
it was basically all the stuff we'd said
because we filmed friday and what tape
friday whatever
this happened last monday um
she said it's so funny watching these
corporations try to
figure out how to deal with my mental
health
they don't know because you can't it's a
bit
like service dogs
it's gray you're like it's a gray area
and if somebody pleads my mental
health it's a it's like exhaustion when
celebrities use right
like it was exhausted and they all ended
up being drug addicts
um every single one of them um
and they it's a you can't call [ __ ]
on my mental health
right so
you know they'll get i
they don't they're gonna they've i don't
envy them because the
in the the credo in sports is like cut
it out
you [ __ ] and then people were writing
that on my instagram because i
tweeted uh what's your favorite
all-time tennis press conference moment
yeah and and people were like yeah
she should she's an elite athlete
okay right what does this have to do
with interviews
people don't they go well they have to
do interviews because it promotes it
you don't know that yeah you're we
assume it does but
i've never watched a tournament because
i saw the press conference on thursday
do you look forward to the locker room
press conference situation
no almost never they're almost never
interesting
even the the allen iverson practice
thing is 20 years ago
and it's so rare that we still talk
about it like remember that
one time a press conference was
interesting you're right
once and i'm just here so i don't get
fined those are the two
but most of the time it's game in and
game out
we got you know day we're going day to
day and you know we're coming together
we're gelling at the right time
and just you know gotta give the other
team a lot of credit
uh they're a heck of a ball club brian
reagan had a great
joke about you gotta give him a lot of
credit um
which is a guy running to the losing
team's locker room and going like gus
i know you're upset but the other the
winning team
said they got to give us a lot of credit
um so so
yeah like everybody acts like
i i don't envy i don't envy the tennis
thing because they're
they're in it they've been doing it this
way
yeah they seem they it's a lot of it's
just about control
right and just like well we want it this
way we want it
for the press no yeah they think it's
good to they think the press conferences
are good it's like
no how much is it the like
correspondence pushing for that thing
because without that
a whole part of their the reason why
they're at the open and stuff like that
goes away
because they're they're kind of yeah oh
i guess yeah you're right like that
they're protecting their turf of
being a uh
you know it's one thing if it's the
white house right right like they work
for us they owe us information right
but this is just i don't i don't know
why you're pretty
i don't know why you'd protect a part of
your job that's demonstrably stupid
like this obviously they all want to be
they all want to be on tv they want to
be correspondents they have careers but
you can still report from the sidelines
you just don't and they do the thing
with the trophy presentation like that
probably won't go away
i just don't think they were worthwhile
i don't think that there was a
worthwhile thing
yeah it feels like just no one wants to
lose any of their power
at any time so when you budge one thing
it's like we're gonna go with it we're
gonna find you and that's just a way of
controlling yeah and making sure we
still have the press conferences
so people can report it and they get but
it's like
she could just give her own press
conference with no press there
well that's the other that this is the
thing i said somebody said like
it helps with the popularity and i go in
on twitter i go um
really when was the last drake press
conference you saw
artist of the decade wickedly popular
never does anything right never does
anything so and that's the old
i had a discussion with a guy who writes
for the washington post
and was writing an article about dave
and
it was a whole thing but he
i was saying to him like why would
somebody why would a famous comedian
like dave for instance
tell you his story so that you can play
telephone
right and tell the reader and
editorialize however you
can spin it and spin it negatively
positively
whatever there's only two speeds in
those in those articles which is
fawning and then there's one what i call
i ain't no [ __ ] paragraph or like don't
get me wrong
i find some of his trans stuff troubling
like i ain't no [ __ ]
he ain't perfect so and i was explaining
it and he was kind of like well you're
then you're
saying that my entire career is and i'm
kind of like
i don't know what to tell you if the
reason
comedians podcasts are popular the
reason marin people would rather do
marin
than the the new york times is because
i know marin and i he if i tell him cut
it
he will cut it yeah and you're not gonna
leave marin
feeling like i did what the [ __ ] did i
just i'm the only person ever who said
throw the episode away oh no years ago
he did and then we redid it was it just
not
fun or did something happen it wasn't
fun it was a little tonally i didn't
love his tone
didn't love his tone so i had him uh
right can you believe it wild
um so this is a side note
i brought a friend to the comedy store
uh last week and
i went on after maron and my friend goes
i like that cowboy guy
because he was white he has like a
mustache oh yeah and like a denim jacket
and i was like yeah i get it if you
don't know who he is he's like a cowboy
that's very
um so why by naomi osaka
she just was able to it's like why the
players tribune works if it's still
i mean the players tribune is like uh
it's
owned by players and you get to write
essays and
they and they you work with an editor a
writer and they
spruce it they spruce it up for you but
it's like blake wrote an article about
why he doesn't dunk so much anymore like
you can kind of go there and express
yourself
in a way that's uninterrupted and
um
you can think through it you don't have
to you're not relying on
on the spur of the moment she's got
social uh social anxiety you can tell
she is social
she looks very uncomfortable when she's
speaking to
reporters why do that to her
yeah also if you take it out of sports
just
why would if i don't trust you
and you've lied about me and you are a
source of my anxiety
i'm i'm being forced to talk to you and
tell you
personal things about me or i get fined
like when you just put it like no
everyone thinks it's crazy if you break
it down like that but
when it comes to it even if they're not
hostile
no it's not it's never it's never
actually hostile it's always hustle with
how they spin it or how they print it or
what they
what quote they choose to take but no
one
anywhere is in this position but we make
an excuse for it because
they get a lot of money and they get
more money than most people
and they're athletes and we're like well
you're an athlete you're getting paid
[ __ ] you money
yeah but they make a pizza famous drake
and yet no press conferences from drake
right well you need to know
you i need to know what that what
happened to views hey drake what
happened on views
that would be really funny if uh record
companies made them do press conferences
yeah way more problematic though um
so so yeah this the idea that this is
necessary
or especially helpful is
insane just insane i don't and then she
dropped out
and then federer i think hurt himself he
dropped out
he got hurt during a match um
and
and uh i didn't realize how much money
this guy has
better he's been great for he's kind of
got to be close to a billion
by the way guys like that make a lot of
money off the court
um yeah so i guess he won but he
um but bounced
and then the funny thing was a female
tennis player got injured at a press
conference
wow i don't she must have tripped or
something
they're dangerous
she yes ankle injury at
a press conference oh no
imagine i don't know
it was a wild friendship another girl
got arrested
how are you up on this news she fell
and hurt my ankle because i think i it's
in my google
uh no
um mri she's wait so who got arrested
how many
people must you injure press before you
before you finally physically mentally
yeah
oh she got a russian lady a different
lady no that's
that's racist against russians um
yeah to imply that russian russian women
look alike is
insanely racist um
she she last year she fixed a match
there's match fixing in tennis she's
ranked 200th
oh so she's like she's gonna make a
living somehow yeah
uh but she was like there were they
noticed a lot of
betting on that match and then she
started going like oh my arm she was
[ __ ] up in ways that were
a little cartoony and she went to jail
this week
she got bailed out but she was there for
i believe a day so she can't play it
ever again yeah i don't think they're
gonna let her she was there to play
again though
who knows what she had over what tricks
she had up her sleeve this year
i hope she bet that naomi wouldn't win
and then convince naomi to drop out
she's a she's a black widow guys
um the lady who joined the the
nra and she whatever trump something
speaking of trump
good great segue neal
trump went before the tribunal
at facebook um and
did they actually have a meeting they've
never all met
actually there's like 20 of them i think
and they've never been in the same room
on account of the covet
but i bet they use it'd be funny if they
use google messenger and not facebook
um um he's got a
he's not allowed to use instagram or
facebook until after the 2022 midterms
he's
he's basically got a two-year bid he's
gonna do a two-year bid
and and um after that and then they'll
re-they'll
think about it but think about it he
said
he thinks he's getting reinstated as
president in august
so he's got you know when
when the god closes a dory open the
window you know what i mean
um so why does he think that
because they think he thinks he's
they're going to overturn
arizona oh the arizona recount the
recount which i heard is full of
many problems yes um but
um yeah
so you know just crazy [ __ ] queuing on
[ __ ]
yeah um and then laura trump dismissed
it but
it's been uh maggie haberman said it so
i he she just talks to him yeah so
she like to when it's like not it's
always him
right right source is closer exactly
[Music]
so you know we'll put money in your
commissary king
i also it's just weird i mean we talked
about it before but it's weird that
facebook is the one holding trump to
any sort of well that's why
comedians are so valuable is because
politicians aren't going to hold people
to
to certainly not hold people's feet to
the fire
they're not they won't there's no i
can't do [ __ ] about mitch mcconnell
i literally cannot do [ __ ] he he's
[ __ ] up the country as far as i'm
concerned
i can't do anything or chris and cinema
or
joe manchin any of these people um
and the republican party isn't going to
hold
trump to account so facebook has to go
like okay
because they're a publicly traded
company they can be penalized for it
and it's funny that they're worried
about lawsuits i'm sure
because they're although they whatever
whatever statute they're not responsible
for [ __ ] on their platform
i don't think zuckerberg wants to start
be responsible for riots right or
yeah riots or death and myanmar or any
of that [ __ ]
so one country sh nigeria just shut
twitter down this week
there's like no no thank you somebody
twitter
the president of nigeria got a real
twitter karate
uh yeah
he basically tweeted something
threatening of
people in his country and then they
blocked him
they blocked the president of nigeria
and then he was like i'll do you one
better
i'm blocking your whole website from my
whole country
no i mean i'm kind of on his side on
that why
[ __ ] him if they're gonna block me [ __ ]
you now no one gets to
no one gets to play well
and i turned out fine i know what you're
getting at let me clear his throat
that's our new song for me clearing my
throat we could well you'll cut that out
that one yeah let him
let him let him growing on us so
whatever so that god bless these social
media companies i don't know but they're
in an impossible if someone if if
trump was like no twitter's but
twitter's banned for everyone in america
well okay then
then i would care but it's nigeria so
it's they deal a little differently over
there they do
it's not like who am i to take away a
black man's agency
bianca black man has his own agency
for me to black man to take my privilege
and in any way judge i'm bianca
i would never you know that's not me
speaking of
racism go
explain to me about this braces to cover
okay so it was so
we talked last week about how wuhan that
might have come from election
yeah they're
the reason this was not a fringe
theory the they had the only um
[Music]
there's a lab in luhan that collects
coronaviruses yeah and studies them
and develops them it's the only one in
china
yeah i think it's been around for a
while right but
like everyone knows everyone didn't know
that i didn't know that and i
and i all i did was sit in bed and hit
refresh you didn't know
at the beginning they were talking about
i didn't catch it
so there's a movie about that almost
mirrors chronovirus it's like a russian
movie and it's about
a coronavirus escaping from that wuhan
now you're expecting me to know russian
movies i'm not i'm just saying
that i felt like a lot of people were
just talking about the lab theory
because
of the wuhan lab i mean you heard about
the world i thought it was the wet
market
all i heard was what you never heard
wuhan like no no
i re i i'm not i have no reason to lie
about that no i know why but
i all i knew was it came from the white
market which seemed plausible because
wet markets are gross
they're disgusting so of course um it it
flatters my biases so basically this was
not a fringe theory
calling it saying that it came from the
the lab
was never really legacy media covered it
was never in the washington post new
york times
guardian any of that [ __ ] very much
bianca
relative to the wet market would you
give me a 10 to 1 ratio
no i'm so when the only reason why
i have a confused face on is because i
when it was all going down and
everyone's like where the [ __ ] does come
from what's going on in china what's
going to move on
i heard that's where i heard that it
could have come from a lab
or it could have come from a wet market
and no one is
denying anything and no one's saying
they're just saying it most likely came
from an animal
right but legacy media was
mostly saying wet market that's
in my my i can't do a ratio search but
you could whatever you could do a google
search
you have to it's you're not the right
person you don't know you're
great we're crazy about you the way you
came in with
what happened to your week i
there's some there was a texting issue
that we'll cover later
right wuham lab leak it just spiked
in
[Music]
wow well yeah it just spiked
so it wasn't it wasn't common so i'm
sorry
i was on the forefront yeah you were on
the forefront i bought uh go
back do two years instead of
um yeah do wuhan lab like past five
years past five years past five years
past five years
yeah it did whatever that is that's
whatever that is is where that's a
little that's almost five to
six to one no no for sure i just mean
that is that spike is where i heard it
yeah so i always thought look at wet
mark
wuhan went market we couldn't we just
never knew the
reason yeah yeah wet market
yeah i've never this is the most
satisfied i've ever been with the chart
yeah maybe in my whole life and will is
at the helm i mean
so many things came together for this
for this to happen
it's so exciting basically the chart
says
that the wuhan lab leaks uh searches on
google
peaked in
[Music]
in march 20 march 20th of 2020
yeah right and the wuhan lab leak
searches peaked in
uh may of 2021.
so if i could do this with everything i
talk about
i would be a much happier person but i
do think
you know nothing but i do think this was
obvious
what do you mean like it was clear that
one dominated and now another dominated
i was just saying well no you were
saying you i i thought you were implying
that
the lab league thing was common it was
not a no no
i'm just saying that i heard it right
enough that that
this isn't the first time i'm hearing
about it that's all i'm saying yeah i'd
hurt that's why i'm like
i'm talking about it but it was always
like there was a guy who was on rogan
and bill maher
um who but it was like probably in the
last six months
who was kind of saying there's some [ __ ]
in this in the
in the genome of this that are like
field lab
labby i would like so i if you watch the
those like i don't know medical fireside
chats that we had with
like every day and you thought you would
come on i remember one of them where he
said
that he can't say it didn't come from a
lab they don't know where it came from
he feels like because it
is similar to sars and merce which came
from
an animal and it has similar proteins
that he's betting it's not from the lab
but the people in the lab got sick so
he's like i can't tell yeah that was
recently
he said that in the last month i believe
okay but i'm just saying oh whatever it
doesn't matter we're saying something
i'm just saying that you're not like
proving something no no i don't think i
am it's more like biden
the white like the now that
because they were afraid that it would
be weaponized against asian people
yeah right that's wrong to me
because it's you're being dishonest
wait were they being dishonest because
we have way more information now than we
did in
april 2020. you know what i mean i don't
think we have much more information
you think we have more i mean i don't
know i don't think it's the ninth grade
you know what i mean but i don't think
it's night and day i think i think that
the
there was a 60-minute story about it
yesterday where that when all the
scientists went there
like in mass and whatever yeah what did
they say
they said that there were two there was
a pro guy and an anti-guy the pro guy
said i'm i've been dealing with the uh
the national health organization for
my whole life i'm like the china i'm the
china guy
for the for the for the for code for for
the
for the nhs the nhl
um or the who yeah um and um
and then there was a guy that's like
they all got sick
people in the lab got sick that's i
think the new information
which has been the past couple weeks you
know what it is i think the reason why
i'm thinking about it like this is
because
i also don't get all my information from
just liberal
super far left you know what i mean so
that
information if you aren't watching super
far left you're right where they were
like
we're not gonna call the china virus
we're gonna go the opposite
so we are nothing like trump right and
that's
where i go that's not right
you can't shade things
to because people will weaponize it
against the group
it's like yeah you can't even with the
israeli and palestinians they
while it is very shaded toward israelis
because they don't want another
holocaust
it's you still knew that the israelis
were bombing hamas
it wasn't like they didn't bomb hamas
they would just
go like there were like 200 palestinians
killed in like
a an israeli and they wouldn't they
would act like that wasn't
a 200 to one ratio but they didn't not
cover it
do you know what i mean they would shade
a little bit but they wouldn't go no
that was just something fell
that wasn't an explosion there was
something fell in a building that
building was uh
set to it collapsed for no reason
um so i feel like you're
sitting on something no i'm just trying
to understand i don't know
it's like how do you because they should
have said
that it might have come from a lab but
to your point they didn't want to be
they didn't want to be china irish they
didn't want to be
they didn't want to play into trump's
anti-asian sort of uh dog whistling
but i think also less you know
a less righteous and more realistic
reason is because
like when chernobyl happened it's not
like
right now is not a time to point fingers
it's what we got to mitigate this issue
and then obviously you have a
committee and you do your research and
you figure out what exactly happened in
my head i just thought
everyone was holding out to point the
blame at exactly what happened because
there was we were also in the middle of
a pandemic i understand
one got clearly skewed that one way and
not the other but
i don't think anybody no one ever said
it
is you think it's like not telling
somebody bad news
when you're getting bad news or when
they're when when they're
when you if someone if you're at a
funeral don't say you know he
he choked himself jerking off right or
like
and they need china to play ball because
china had so much information
i still don't think they played ball the
way they should
i'm not sure if they did or not i'm just
saying if you need
information from someone who's been
dealing with the coronavirus
probably like six months ahead of you
then i don't know i just feel like they
were just being extra careful for a
million reasons that i don't know if
they were that
there is a part of me and i'm liberal
who thinks like
that's what happened they were they were
as much as you're
you could paint it as being thoughtful
or considerate
i don't think it's also considered i
think everyone's really careful before
they criticize china well yeah but they
didn't they were
pretty quick about the wet market they
didn't go we don't want to
harm the wet market because a wet mark
is a lot easier to say like oh just a
cultural market as opposed to like
y'all did some [ __ ] they [ __ ] up i
think they just [ __ ] up
i don't think that they i don't think
that they intentionally leaked it
but china was not being forthcoming
hey you guys we [ __ ] up so they were
also like i remember
people saying like china is not giving
us right numbers they're saying oh no
it's we're fine here
and meanwhile they are actually like
still
shutting down whole cities even when
they were saying they were finding
photos of wuhan people in like uh i
don't know welding people into their
homes one of my favorite things ever
what because they were welding people i
just think it's like that's what i would
do
that's what you would do it's my life
yeah it's called blaming the victim it's
a lifestyle
um i just think it's not as easy as oh
let's just go against the
the let's just go against trump i don't
think it's that
obvious but i
and i don't particularly saying it's a
bit of a scapegoat
like an easy it's an easy like easy
target and it doesn't it
yeah i don't i i it's service dogs it's
service dogs yeah i still think it's
like
ah they they if it had been
uh i don't know if canada i mean
liberals where do liberals like to
attack
but think about it take it outside
because this is an american viru
pandemic this happened everywhere a lot
of countries
did not go and say it was your [ __ ]
labs even though a lot of countries had
similar
well because the who wouldn't give them
good information
so like i'm so then i'm saying like it's
like it's not a
trump versus you know like it's not as
politicized as you think because there
were other countries yeah
but i think i think we have one idea
take up 24
30 of the oxygen in the u.n and the
whole
tom york one time from radiohead said
that
and i used to make this joke on spell
show which is tom york would say
uh radiohead is the u.n and i'm america
oh no like we're just like i'm gonna get
yeah
portion of like [ __ ] bossiness um
so oh dude this is interesting another
sports story
tell me exactly we should do two sports
stories in a row well we're gonna
well we're gonna call an audible sports
term
um pga guy
professional golfer uh
he's up by six shots okay after saturday
it's like kind of a blowout
okay show the video will go to
uh go to youtube there's video
watch his uh reaction when he
yeah watch his reaction this is them
telling him he has
they tell him he has covet this is a
commercial that i did not direct
because it's not it's not very much fun
sort of i don't like this tone
he can i can it's it's a little it's not
good it's a little muted it's not bad
it's just a little muted
now you got it now that we put it in
tiger woods terms oh sorry
yeah just like literally you're
disqualified
now here's the good question i think i
just saw your brain go there as well
john did you get the vaccine uh john
looked a little
right wingy john looking like he
john do you believe vaccines do you
believe code's real now john
john's looking a little john uh
yeah like that's one of those things
where it's like i feel like this could
have been avoided
the funny thing is the two guys he
played with weren't worried about it
because they
both had covet yeah because they so it's
like yeah
we [ __ ] around and got it yeah um now
if he got
if he did get the vaccine it's a
historic level tragedy yeah now but he
didn't
do we know let's ask will
didn't get it ha
you want to talk about losing out on the
covent lottery
buddy get the shot
um if rahm had been vaccinated asap
after
after his home state of arizona opened
eligibility to all
adults on march 24th the 26 year old
spaniard almost certainly would have
avoided testing positive
um and he would have gotten 1.6 million
dollars but
you know bianca we all have a price why
y'all
you can't buy john rams you can't pay
john ram to believe in science
i think john i think he just john ram
no he's doubling down he's like [ __ ]
this
i know somebody who got it and who
wouldn't who would talk about it like it
was fake and then it
got it and then i go so what do you
think now he's like
i still think they exaggerate that i
think the press exaggerates it's like
you're not gonna get people to say
um you know
that they were [ __ ] dead wrong right
no i have someone who was just like no
sending me uh she's like did you see
this and it was the
bill and melinda gates foundation sign
it was like bill and melinda gates
foundation
for cloning humans i'm like stop sending
me
this this is stupid uh and then she hit
me up
talking about so did you get moderna or
which one has less side effects i'm
trying to go for the one with less side
effects i'm like
well i don't care if you change your
mind i don't care if you change your
mind
no no but it was all just like ah like
it was still
i don't believe in this i have to do
this for work
and right but it just it's finding a way
to still keep
their integrity yeah well yeah to still
with themselves uh okay i'm gonna
take it but but hold on one second
um so pga guy i mean
you pe you look you sometimes every once
you're a great
historic figure who who paid the price
for his beliefs you're up there with
bill russell
tell us about bill russell dad uh bill
russell of course won 10 nba
championships
won't sign autographs for any white
people especially
who is this guy bill russell's the
greatest nba player of all time you'll
recognize him
did he play for the knicks he played for
the celtics
he's like the best he's a great man
he's a really great man how come this
guy and bill russell in the same way i'm
kidding
i'm kidding like you're i don't know
enough john rams the
muhammad ali of anti-vaxxers wait
he doesn't sign oh he doesn't sign
autographs for white people
uh he doesn't decide autographs for
anybody
okay i don't believe in autographs let's
have a cup of coffee instead
i like him he's great he's great super
folksy
[ __ ] incredible basketball player hat
wrote read a wrote a book called second
wind
that i read and yeah actually great has
a
really funny about object observation
about l.a what
which is people think that scheduling
meetings
is a job and he made an observation like
68.
how old is this guy 80. wow um
is he the one who played larry bird no
sorry
no he's he he's 110 champion he's 87.
he's won 10 championship he's the
winningest player and he was a player
coach
awesome and he was like he's a logo no
he's not the
white guy logo get don't be crazy they
had to make a white guy logo
um what are you out of your mind uh bill
russell said something funny in this
book which is
at one point he jumped so high
he was scared at the top
because he didn't know how he was gonna
land
that's am i crazy he gave me goosebumps
he was like he didn't know how he was
gonna lie he was like
i don't know how and i've asked players
about it and they were like no
like they were all he just it's back
when
basketball was like the wild west right
um
yes so john ram is the muhammad ali of
antibacters
um you they can't buy you john ram they
offered you 1.6 million dollars to get
the vaccine and you
said no which is spanish for
no because you're also spanish john ram
how uh how how mad is he when he gets a
vaccine though
now he's definitely not getting involved
no he's just like [ __ ] yeah yeah
well for what because by the way now
that he's gotten it he won't need it and
he'll do the antibody game
um long story but if you i think if you
have antibodies and you get
the shot you're good forever i don't
know if i told you
well what are we you might be good
forever that's what they think
yeah forever why uh i don't know
because you have such a like high count
of antibodies
i will say i uh got
extremely sick on the first one and the
nurses were saying
most people who have had coveted get
really sick on the first one because
your body's like
wait a minute everybody's never seen it
no no your body's like this [ __ ]
again
oh well the fir oh the oh the first shot
the first shot got it yeah yeah um
and then there there's an nfl story
that's so creepy
too uh the race norming thing oh yeah
it's
first of all i didn't i actually didn't
know what race norming was
that good stuff hit click the race
arming his bigotry that began with good
intentions
okay so i know what it is basically they
race norming is when they do sort of
intelligence tests for black players
they thought it would be cool if they
made the assumption that black players
had lower iqs than white
players no cognitive function okay
iq or cognition whatever um cognitive
function they assumed that black players
would have
lower cognitive baseline cognitive
functions than
white players which
uh i
i don't even know where to begin on that
sounds racist to me i'm gonna have to
unpack it a little bit
just this doesn't really happen smell
the
the smell test um
so basically all right well in 1980 the
department of labor pressured employers
to adjust aptitude test scores
to improve the performance of black
people who often did worse than white
people
scroll up well or down yet the equal
threat to suit companies not adopting
such race norming
racial adjustments also became widely
used in medical diagnosis
like how black women aren't given
aspirin because you because you can take
so much pain
um racer was imposed with the best
intentions to help combat discrimination
i understand that like i understand how
they were well it was because of
apparently in um like a lot of uh
federal jobs
yeah because the tests were racist
right against black people they put in
the race norming to even the playing
field
and then of course conservatives didn't
like it i think i've heard the argument
that they weren't racist
how do you make a test racist um i think
it's i asking them about [ __ ] only why
people could know
or you just different like i don't know
because i didn't get into
what was racist about the test like how
is a test racist
if everyone has access to it you know
and it's just apparently one of the
questions that they used to put on tests
was
about it was about walking
barefoot in your house which black
people never do because they wear house
shoes
um and they had to get rid of that
question that was one of the very racist
that's a joke question
black people in my experience warehouse
shoes
proportionally eight to one to white
people it's like do you wash your meat
well do you wash your meat do you wash
your legs do you
of course of course of course of course
of course um the classic washcloth uh
that you guys
we did it you guys did it that was us uh
but basically
they apparently in when they used in
medicine from what i read
uh because of systemic racism in the
medical industry
against black people and all the reasons
why
all you know we get that part they have
a higher rate of dementia
in black folks so they were saying they
kind of wanted to
uh use race norming to
test the cognitive function function as
a baseline to say like no it's not
that they are more prone to dementia
it's because of like all these outside
factors whatever anyways
the nfl uses it to say like your
baseline is lower than
a non-black person your baseline
cognitive function is lower
they use it in like these guidelines
that they well they kind of make it
hot they raise black people's cognitive
function right
basically they were doing ct make it
worse whatever is worse
they were doing cognitive functioning
tests right and
black people were getting less money
black players were getting less
settlement
because because they
normed their cognitive function higher
so therefore they were
it was it seemed like they did their
brains were just damaged
because for whatever they would race
norm
i guess the the cognition on the cte
test
it's just one of those nightmares just a
nightmare like a nightmare policy
that you can't believe they were doing
it basically when you want to say hey i
got dementia
and i need compensation the
tools that they were that the doctors
had to use even though they aren't nfl
doctors to evaluate you
are racist so the doctors along with the
wives of the people suffering from
dementia basically
joined together and were like this come
on guys
like you so we're just gonna say all
these black players
were just like low to begin with so
how bad can you mention it you i mean
you're barely your brain was barely
working
it's a washcloth look at you in your
house shoes
but now they're gonna go re-evaluate and
like i don't what i don't get is why the
the nfl has so much money why not just
take care of people i know of course hey
we're not going to give out money for
free but
why not just have it in your class like
if you have dementia we will
uh because they just that many people
nfl
owners are like cartoon white people
they're all just like cartoons [ __ ]
like jerry jones they're just so
capitalist white robert kraft jerry
jones they just like
they're they're like
tanned they're like red
a little bloated robert craft apparently
petitioned to get the deflategate
investigation taken away like robert
kraft looks like a just
you know that's the guy that got that
meme where he's walking no that's
actually not him
oh that's a
roy williams coach in north carolina
where he memes in fact i sent it to the
i sent that meme to the guy who's trying
to get me to rebuild my walk
he's like you won't want to walk like
roy williams that's really funny um
oh yeah i've gotta bend my knees yeah
they look the same yeah they all look
if you couldn't tell these like they're
all reading for the same part
they're all they're they're all they're
all in the room they know each other
the owner of the red the raiders right
there that guy's
that guy's the
he's nepotism case oh no
um to call him a nepotism case is
kind i mean it's unbelievable also he
looks like thomas he used to manage a
comedy store
yeah same eyes
so they just i mean there's not even
like even if you took the nfl could take
care
at least to some degree all of the
players that have been the nfl there's
not that many well
that's the funny thing is like the
amount of guys that have played in the
nba
is like three thousand it's like so not
nba same
yeah well like roughly the same or no uh
the nfl has more bigger teams so there's
probably more but it's probably i don't
know ten thousand twelve thousand yeah
it's not
that many people who can say they played
for this yeah
organizations with a really nice search
uh 26 000 players of all time
ever that's nothing and that's a lot of
them are dead
yep thanks to football yeah thanks to
what they when they suited up yeah like
they're all
so so it's it's uh
23 000 that's an old one so yeah 6 000
have died
that's back from 2014 there were 17 000
still alive
so it's just like they're cartoon
rich white guys and they don't it's like
they
they also won't build a stadium unless
taxpayers pay for it they just they will
do the worst
possible thing like look at that group
of guys
they're just not like a no nice group
and some of those are not owners
um but okay yeah
so just low bar what about does it
change with basketball and baseball and
all that stuff for no not really
not really i mean basketball players are
starting to own teams so that's cool
uh dwyane wade shaquon's part of
uh sacramento dwyane wade just got a
part of um
phoenix uh grant hill
i believe look at grant hill
hawks
yeah so grand hill's part of that um
[Music]
and told me uh told me how much you put
in
good good chunk yeah not not nothing not
like
not nothing not for nothing um
good dude was that the was that the um
the
the mark twain thing oh um you didn't
say hi to me
that's odd i'm sorry i'm sorry that that
happened here
um so
anyhow um yeah so race norming
good try good try you were gross
rest and rest in power okay moving on
still the best way to say goodbye to
somebody it is cat williams
what happened mainstay of
of uh it was on the joe budden pockets i
don't know if we can use it but
all of the people that didn't make it to
the nba
if you ask them if we just look forward
to gold down another foot
they all tell you they make it
nobody likes the outer bounds but the
out of bounds gotta be there
or you'll run up in the stands right so
some of these things are for the benefit
of everything
nobody likes the speed limit but it's
necessary nobody likes the shoulder of
the road but it's there for a reason
my point is uh people
weren't all that extremely funny back
when they could say whatever they wanted
at the end of the day there's no
canceled culture
cancellation doesn't have its own
culture that was
people of color that was us policing our
own culture that was
people without a voice being
trashed by people just because they had
a bigger name in them and more
money than them and a better office
than them they could sweep them up under
the rug like they didn't matter
i don't know what people we think got
canceled
that's the the appointment
who the so the as a guy's making a thing
about this
but
kevin hart lost the oscars or stepped
down for the office he didn't
get didn't get fired made it so
uncomfortable that he didn't want to
host anymore
um nobody's as cats
who's gotten canceled for real for real
right
and then which leads me to my next
thought which is being a comedian
is the only job you can say anything
it's like i talked to ian edwards about
it i was like dude think about the [ __ ]
you say in the first five minutes of
your act
you would be fired from every single job
on earth
rather than comedians so not only are we
not under attack
where we're like kind of cherished
in a weird way to say things that are
not
especially this day and age people are
big fans of comedians bigger than they
were like 10 years ago you know
and that's the other thing it's like
yeah with great money comes great
you just have to if you're going to do
arenas you're going to have
you're going to be on the cover of the
thing that eddie and
dice had in common when they were both
he got
is they were doing arenas right it's
kind of the cost of doing arenas it's
like kev was doing arenas
once you do arenas then people will hold
you to this other thing
and you can either apolog whatever
however you want to handle it
but that's my favorite kat williams
point
since michael jackson being a pedophile
finally speaking some sense
i i just think what
i think cancer culture has always been
around i don't know why we're
labeling it something new i think when
it came to me
too that was a new thing of
corporations essentially and like
governments being like cool
let's maybe believe some of this more
than we have
same thing with like blm now it's just
more everyone's more on
board the more favorable thing to do is
maybe believe this person as opposed to
write it off
right definitely not automatic dismissal
right
that's kind of as much as the needles
move we think it's more because we're
all cued into like
hashtags and celebrities yeah oh my god
but
it's like when people get mad at us
sometimes
i feel like oh my god all these people
mad at me but there's like it's four
people
it's four people yeah it's four people
who wrote me in a similar time frame
right and it's four people it's also me
and cat we're talking about it
they're trained to do it yeah
they're trained they're on a they're on
a platform twitter
facebook yeah instagram whatever tick
tock
um that incentivizes them to go like
bianca is [ __ ] up or read it or
wherever they do it
so they don't actually care no
no one is thinking about me the moment
they like something jars their attention
and they're like okay let's go
yeah and they get there personally leave
no one is no one is still thinking about
me so
i mean i'm just using me as an example
it's not that dramatic but
it's always been around and like before
there was a common thing there was just
i don't know how was it when
uh kramer got canceled like how was that
in comedy
uh what do you mean you know when he was
like
yeah at the laugh factory what was the
fallout because that was kind of before
this sort of [ __ ] like what was that for
a comment
that was like the that was kind of the
opening shot
because that was that that was
he got canceled for sure for sure but
how did that play
how popular was he before that right but
i'm wondering as a comedian
how did him being canceled play out
without the without the facility
the social media facilitation platforms
had just been built
one of them camera phones was 2008 right
camera phone started
0.708 it's the first camera phone
karen whatever the [ __ ]
and it was tmz which was the right
cancellation platform of the 2000s
so and then
twitter was nascent and i'm sure it got
some traction but
um so it was like would you still say hi
like were people did he come to the
club he didn't well the funny thing is
the laughter said they banned him
it it happened on friday night right he
did the saturday night show
lies or so i've been told i don't know
if it's
right um so
it wasn't i don't i mean i think it was
probably just like ah that was weird
right and then once it became a video
problem then it was like a real thing
right but i just think you know we have
always had this cancelling like
if you think about it the farther back
you go you did one wrong thing you're a
witch
yeah uh die or you know
no you shouldn't have this yeah you have
a bastard son you can't be here
madonna's a [ __ ]
monica lewinsky's a [ __ ] like there's
the right wing's been doing it
for as long as anybody um and
the the thing that comes to mind is joe
rogan and mencia
i know with redband's video yeah joe
kinda canceled carlos joe canceled
carlos
inside baseball joe did not cancel
carlos sure he did
he still would mind him and sia it was
they couldn't cancel it immediately no
of course but i mean like he went from
doing
theaters to clubs like really
yeah he was really diminished
like greatly diminished that's crazy
yeah
yeah like he really i mean but that's
a righteous cancellation if you're if
you get a guy for stealing jokes and he
admits it like
right i just mean like that i felt like
that was for
comedy heads more than it was it made
ripples
and it had huge ripples really huge
because if you're comedy central
you can't really promote a guy that's a
admitted joke thief but do you think
mencia was a situation where he was
cancelled
in the like in the behind the scenes
version and not
by a whole like people you think if he
could still do theaters he'd be doing
theaters they're not i think that fans
went with him yeah they're booking him
into clubs because that's
the amount of demand that he has wild
no i know it's very like it's a one i
forget but
um so but i don't think that's what
cat's talking about cat's talking about
this idea that comedians are being you
know
pilloried for saying crazy [ __ ] it's
like
dave gets the occasional article and
then just talks about it a bunch no
so it's saying you can say what they
want they're getting canceled like also
we're not talking about a lot of
comedians that are getting canceled
are getting cancelled for behavior
outside of comedy
right yeah that's that that's so it's
like yeah it happens to be with
comedians yeah they happen if their job
happens to be comedian but it wasn't
because of delia's joke about germans or
whatever
or the orange tree yeah but what about
one
like what happened to tony and stuff
like that like when it's about your joke
oh with tony saying i don't know i think
that's the thing i don't
i don't know tony hinchcliffe called the
mc
uh derogatory asian slang term and
the guy posted it and
tony got dropped by that i also don't
think tony's that canceled either
right it didn't affect his viewers at
all it didn't affect
no one's not watching kill tony now
because of that
they're just like oh i didn't know you
were doing this show i didn't know
you're an awesome [ __ ] you should have
told me tony
um so i think yeah it's it's
hard to really cancel something truly
yeah without
just joking well the kid didn't get snl
what's his name oh yeah but that that's
you know that's damn again cancel
damn it canceling is shaming somebody
and depriving them of opportunities
so i guess occasionally people do get
cancelled
um i do think though a lot of
cancellations can be mitigated by
uh i don't know do you think apologies
work
or do you think people like no no no i
don't
people like crossing their arms it's
more satisfying to cross your arms
than to be but give someone grace yeah
there's no you don't get clicks from
being great from giving someone grace
you get it from
flaming them um
so and then there's also the thing where
like shane gillis
i think probably makes i was talking
i've been talking to
kat about you and i and then roy and and
trayvon about
some as we never if we say something
illiberal we lose liberals and gain no
conservatives
right so it's not
thankless but it's like we get penalized
for mistakes but we don't get rewarded
for them whereas a guy like shane gillis
was like mid center right anyway right
so
he gets called racist by
a bunch of liberals and then they're
like conservatives are like come on man
come on man
we don't we don't like them anyway and
so that whereas
you and i as liberals just get nothing
we get penalized but no reward and
it's gotta end um well that's a good
segue yes talk about it um there was a
study that said because uh
do you see the story no no no i haven't
yeah i just forgot to write
um and it was they did a national
study and it said that conservatives are
more susceptible to believing falsehoods
but
the the way they did the study was
interesting is that they took
so liberals and conservatives both
believe
false stories that favor their side
politically both of them
can call out neutral
politically neutral stories that don't
favor their side
everybody calls out the the falsehoods
equally
like everyone's like yeah no that's
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
if it doesn't benefit them politically
the reason why it's uh slanted towards
conservatives is because
um i mean with just boiling it down it's
literally because one there's way more
misinformation that
is beneficial to the conservative
political viewpoint there's just more
misinformation right and
i mean in layman's terms when i read the
article
the liberal's
viewpoint is just more truthful
[Music]
yeah i mean that doesn't surprise me it
it
of course we think that because we're
liberals no no this person
i don't know he just did a independent
study yeah
yeah i just as a liberal it's hard to go
like well our side no of course it'd be
like well and we were more true though
it was just things that
he they were he was saying that like
were
demonstrably untrue like
like absolutely did not happen at all
but if it benefited a conservative's
political viewpoint then
it was like yep nope that's the truth
you know so yeah and there was just
more of that and there's just more
misinformation
out there in the um like in the
conservative
yeah yeah so the environment is just
chocolate it's a swamp it's gross yeah
it's a it's a swamp it made me feel like
no way to solve this how do you solve
there's no way to solve that
institutionally i don't know how you
solve it
because it's as i've said on here before
it's a skinny mirror
so they're just gonna find the skinny
mirror if you're at a store
so you're driving along um and
if you're at a store and they have a
skinny mirror
and you're trying clothes on you're
gonna go to the skinny mirror
right you're gonna be like i look really
good and then they move if they move the
mirror
you're just gonna go this mirror is
broken
and they're going to find the skinny
mirror and that's what's going to happen
with conservative
lies and liberalize like you'll just
find where it's
both actually believed
their lies similarly it's just there's
more lies than conservative that's all
really it is right yeah that makes sense
it's not that liberals are more
honorable it's just there's less
opportunities
there's just less opportunity to believe
lies yeah which is
i was just a bummer yeah it's a very
hard problem to solve even the
with the documentary with cancer culture
stuff it's like
yeah the conclusion it's just
hard
it's like we need a uh
ideological cleanse yeah that's
and it's it and then it's gonna be up to
like okay you go
first who's going to go first because
there's there's advantages to just
just playing the cancel game have you
looked into the history because
obviously
you know when this has happened in the
past when people are just so
ideologically
divided what's happened like you can go
back in time with
i don't know yeah there's a
there's a very interesting podcast about
it's called uh what up homes which is an
aggravating title
i believe it's radio lab but it's about
oliver wendell holmes
you used to not be able to be against
you used to not be able to publicly
speak out against war
in america what and um
and then
it went back to the supreme court and
oliver wendell holmes
overturned it because
and said you could there that there was
free there should be free speech right
but you couldn't there was no free
speech about war which is a pretty big
one
right and if you think about it just
because the overturning doesn't mean it
was
popular to talk bad about war right but
the only reason
he basically young people got to him
and it was i think it was his experience
he was in world war
one or there was a war he was in and he
was like don't talk bad about
he didn't like that people talk about
the work because he was in it right and
then
young people got to him and sort of was
like yeah you should let so whatever
it's interesting
um anyhow the
what about the drug charges oh i was
just gonna say
when i was i was reading about just
i was just reading about uh restorative
justice and all that stuff
and i didn't realize 70 percent
of drug no 78 of drug charges in this
country
are for a gram or less 70
8 78 78 jesus christ are for
less than a gram which is like an
orthodontist rubber band bag right
right like classic right just the lit
like
trace amounts and then
78 for our are a fun night or less
and then 70 of drug charges
are just weed so that's
not a lot of weed it's not it's barely
enough to get you hot
yeah it's insane it's insane it's uh
wild and of course i mean the all the
all the players are there slanted
against black people
crack same crack over 50 less than a
gram
um almost never is it over a killer it's
never the big players of it it's just
the
local guys wow it's all
yeah weeds less than 50 less than a gram
but
it whatever it it's yeah they should
i hope that they get out soon all those
people
i think do you think that's actually
gonna happen i don't know i mean
it should i did a joke that the the
problem they made is
the the mistake they made is they
shouldn't have called themselves weed
dealers and they should have called
themselves
cannabis entrepreneurs people white
people like that
a lot and talk about cbd
um good job
that's about the only one yeah no that's
a good weed song that was a good read
yeah that sounds more weird yep
skunk weed let's be clear not good weed
bammer
yeah um clarence williams iii
rest in power king or
as i was i wrote on here
uh rest cuban b he's the guy who said
cuban b
it's so funny did he make that uh yeah
didn't i tell you yeah
yeah yeah he that me and dave were
smoking or something [ __ ] around and
they had started rehearsal
without us yeah do you really like like
all right
uh any do you want to get
asked the writers and the star that's no
big deal
and uh and then clarence was irritated
and said uh gamma said i'm cuban b and
he goes yes cuban b
hilarious so insane and
um yeah so that guy was great
he was great and i loved him in tails in
the hood tails night he's [ __ ]
fantastic
in the hoodies it's who
like rusty conduct the guy who directed
a bunch of chappelle show [ __ ] directed
that movie
no yeah rusty um
in fact you know what you want to hear
an old man come on to the premiere
the premiere of tails tails relax from
the hood it would have been
fun as hell
[Music]
it was i love the i love there's also
the term that don johnson uses in this
movie that
boy must've had weak bones uh no
it's uh it's for the
tiny black people that yeah
niglets there you go that's the one i
can quote the whole thing it's a very
it's just good it's
frightening all the stuff that's one of
those things where like i don't under
that's like some
some just some racist [ __ ] where rusty
didn't get a bigger
bump from that i it's all of the stories
first of all it's just like so
[ __ ] weird like he had done fear of a
black hat and that
within three years of each other all he
did sprung which i guess bombed but
but two out of three like respectable
movies
uh it was it's really hard to make scary
movies
it's just that interesting they were
interesting
they like i guess the dues that are kind
of like the
chorus for the just like the
the in between it's almost like uh tales
from the crypt
the crypt keeper tells you little
vignettes yeah whatever
they're all so good they're so scary the
little
you know slaves that come off the that
one is this scariest one
i'm like can you imagine living slaves
so terrifying
this is like did jordan feel that one i
feel like
and starring binky there you go uh but
no really
the fact that it's not
why more like widely it's weird because
it it to me it was
a good movie i guess it didn't it's
budget it made 11.8 which is kind of
what half baked made
yeah look at it if you like if you like
horror watch tales from the hood
it's very good what a half big man
seventy five good seventeen five
eight million dollar budget to which uh
darren aronofsky
said where did it all go oh rude
you know pretty rude but you know it's a
fair shot that's funny what did
what is is he has any clunkers darren
he's got a lot of clunkers yeah but then
he has like
black swan killers oh yeah blacks on
killers go down
what no neil i mean he's got
pie requiem for a dream the fountain was
a stinker
the phone was not good uh the wrestler
was a hit
black swan was a hit noah was a stinker
mother was a stinker
mother was not good didn't see rock
loves mother
never watched it uh oh he's not so bad
darren's a great director oh no i love
doing it but it just
he's his batting average is pretty good
yeah um
that amazing story
i believe is going to space no
on his rocket anybody see this
why he's going on the first crude flight
who wants to be the first of things i
don't get that a guy with a death wish
um is he trying to like out
weird out bad idea elon musk
some that's having an asperger's
competition oh no um
i've ever since i was five years old
i've dreamed of traveling to space
yeah this is what i want to say when
people bring up their childhood dreams
children are [ __ ] dumb
so when they go i've since i was this
small yeah and then you grow up
and you go that's dangerous have you was
there something you wanted to do and
then you
i mentioned this the other day at some
point i was
me and a buddy of mine were gonna split
a trans am when we got older we were
going to get a trans am
split and we're going to split it we're
going to go
on it um that's a dumb idea
but that's how a child thinks yeah i did
say that i wanted to have a job where i
could wear sneakers
well which you know i knew that if
that meant being an athlete or whatever
the [ __ ] this
is whatever i've turned into here i
wanted when i was a kid i said i'm gonna
have a
a water fountain in my house that uh
was served orange juice
orange juice orange juice hi-c
i say orange juice [ __ ] by the
way side note that i'm going to need
some help with
come on i bought my first bag of oranges
in the ti all the time i've lived in l.a
like a million to juan oranges or just
from the store
no no a million tawan oranges oh i don't
even know what that means
was that i know the movie you know the
movie paul rodriguez
yeah is it an orange seller he's a he's
a like a
mexican dude that sells orange like bags
of orange
and then somebody gives him a million
dollar check and
an 80s movie ensues it's a 90s movie
um jeff bezos is going to travel with
wait
hold on i bought it i've ten dollars and
i swear to god it's
probably 35 oranges yeah it's a lot it's
by the way cat took five of them and
i've had two of them
so oh you know so many will that's our
cue
i need help guys i'm gonna stop down
right now and have you guys
well help me maybe the orange is why
you're sniffling in the first place
i got i'm the first person to get a cold
from oranges
does that make any sense to anybody
maybe they aren't good
you know what's funny i bought a bag of
oranges from some amigos
and they were like i'm like well i don't
know you know
they're like you want to you want to
taste like you sure
tasted like a juicy well yeah juicy
fruit
they gave you the the floor the floor
model and then
uh when i took them inside uh all of
them were rotted but the non-rotted side
was facing out
that's i mean that's they went overboard
with that they're five bucks i'm like
words so they just buy they bought an
orange from whole foods well yeah that's
what it's like
it's like 38 oranges probably for ten
dollars and it's like are they stolen
oranges
uh are they good though because those
ones were dry they were good they're
good yeah
the one that i had were good the one cat
had was good three or three for so
okay it's pretty interesting it's pretty
interesting i think it's worth
i think it's about time we go behind a
paywall or stuff like that
um so jeff bezos is going into space and
he's bringing his brother mark with him
now what he's half right there which is
send your brother to space right
that's one of those things where you go
you know what mark you're my brother
just check check it out for me report
back
if you come back safe then it's good
um do people not realize how
confined space is i don't i'm so
claustrophobic i'd never be able to do
it
are you closer i bet he's thought it
through i'm not
uh i'm not especially claustrophobic i
actually in fact i like a cocoon
as you know from oh yeah i uh laska when
i went into my little you went into a
cut
which was weird i didn't understand how
you
you you know what you guys old meal
followed up
neal folds um
uh he if you if you scroll up well he
gave a quote which is
um bezos predicted that he would be a
new man after his journey to space it
changes your relationship with this
planet with humanity
it's one earth i want to go on this
flight because it's the thing i've
wanted to do all my life
well no he's not wrong there because
there is this syndrome that happens to
people go to space
i forgot i was called but it basically
when you see
the uh space center
[Music]
space like just um so he
basically astronauts were saying that
when you see
space face is it space face
when you see the um the sun setting and
and rising a million times and you see
uh
like storms over here and this over
there and you just see it all
as a whole in one view you can see our
whole earth and it's only protected by
this tiny layer of atmosphere
you feel so less connected to you know
[ __ ] trump yeah you're just like no man
you're you don't get it yeah the
mountains and the moon and so where did
he could just do ayahuasca a
if he wanted that jeff of course you
know my door's always open
and secondly
yeah all right good i mean [ __ ] it if
this is what it's gonna take for him to
to start doing more environmentally
friendly and okay
and friendly to workers and if that's
what it takes and then when you're done
with that
take the nfl owners one at a time
and then the end and they want to we'll
go one at a time
um doc watch
oh wait i had a [ __ ] oh yeah no you
really hear the story
okay neil i need your help with my
anybody here these stories okay
so one this is all basketball related i
don't get him but
people were talking about him why are
people
talk making fun of lebron
what's going on with the lakers why are
people saying they always make fun of
lebron
but what what's going on with the lakers
that they're saying you know like
they're losing so bad or they lost they
lost
their series they got exited out of the
first
round is that a big deal it's fine i
mean
again think of it as checkers um
and you'll be fine it's a lot less
because it just dominates my
feed i'm like what you must have
searched for them one too many times
one too many times and then the other
one is kevin garnett
got mad because oh that's very stupid
what can you explain
because kyrie irving used to play for
the
um boston celtics and
didn't enjoy it and then when he went to
the he stopped their logo
wait what do you mean he just this is
the most childish thing you can think of
he just
he just like rubbed his foot in it so
funny
dude and it's very embarrassing
um it's like so childish
okay here we go walking up to the
walking up to the logo
yeah rubbed his foot on it scratched his
foot did you catch that
also very hard to even see then i heard
he gave the toilets
an upper decker and then i heard he put
it's like yeah i don't it's so corny
they gave you 38 million dollars dude
like it's their corporation it's like
being loyal to [ __ ]
apple or microsoft it's so it's like
guys who have
nike tattoos or jordan tattoos right
just like oh you corny [ __ ]
right blake texted me about
doing a sketch about it about what just
about about kyrie why did kevin garnet
get mad because he played for the
celtics so it's all corny on both sides
it's coronate it's
quadruple corny cause you've a corny
it's a corny it's a
gangbang recordiness for someone who
loves sports so much
sports are very corny and you don't like
a lot of corny i don't i like basketball
that's what i'm saying
that's it's not inherently corny
stuff like that's corny but
that's not really that's not basketball
to me okay
my basketball needs sharing the ball
it's jazz bianca
i love when people call it jazz they're
improving
out there um no it's not jess it's a
jazz is with trumpets and stuff
um um so
um also jazz needs to get
funded by the government so
it's another difference between
basketball's popular that's why it's not
like jazz
um anyhow sorry shout out to jess rest
in power king
no um so yeah
so it's it's just like corny just corny
[ __ ] yeah just
corny talked about write it off no big
deal just don't even pay attention i'm
sorry i had to see that
sorry thank you basketball's jazz i
bring you all my sports situations yeah
it's fine you came in the right place
it's a safe space thank you
um doc watch
i only date women
i'm not even done with this and it's so
good hulu
it was a big documentary called some
kind of heaven i think
it would if if sundance had happened it
would have won
what was it about was about it's about
you know those retirement
you know like in during the election
there was a lot of people
at a place in florida
that were on golf carts that were like
yelling about trump yeah
the villages oh is it in hollywood
um it's
maybe near hollywood um but
it's it's a retirement community called
the villages and they just
produced by darren aronofsky small world
oh wow the man who shot on the budget of
half-half eggs
guys it's all coming together do you see
the connections um
it's jazz uh lance oppenheim i like how
most documented directors
kind of sound like they come from money
like hop and hunt
drop the earth um yeah um
uh it's great it's really it's sort of
portraiture of people and it covers
maybe six or seven people and just cuts
it's like sort of covers how expansive
the
retirement community is because it's
like they have classes they
all they've movie theater they it's like
a campus
golf course what's going on on this
campus the weird there's [ __ ] weird
people there
really there's like a guy an old guy who
gets who's doing
like tons of drugs he's kind of losing
his mind he goes to
he gets he goes to court he gets busted
with
like less than a gram of weed the judge
is like you're the most
you're the rudest person i've ever had
in my courtroom but he's just out of his
mind like
and his wife who's been married to him
for 47 years is trying to like ride with
him but he's
[ __ ] losing his mind [ __ ] like that
there's another it's just
it's the people are way quirkier than
it i thought it would just be like about
a retirement community it's about a
bunch of [ __ ] weirdos
and you like that of course yeah it's a
new newly single woman
oh and she dates a guy who's cause
there's a lot of [ __ ]
there will be i think at some point um
there's a guy she did she goes on a date
with the guy who sold her golf cart
like you yeah but it's the guy's like
they call him margarita man
and he's like super into jimmy buffett
it's just a bunch of cork
it's a cork fest so i hi i'm not even
done and i suggest watching it
okay now we got a lot of video questions
this week
hey neil and bianca mostly thursday
listener here because
i like to see you guys neil question
about being a comedian a couple podcasts
ago you mentioned not going to a roast
basically because you didn't want to get
roasted and i was wondering about that
from listening to this podcast and
other podcasts with comedians comedians
together seems amazing you're always on
you're always sharp you're always
roasting each other but
does that get exhausting do you need a
break from it or is that your natural
setting
bianca because you work with and hang
out with comedians do you find you need
a break
or is hanging out with comedians like
the top tier group is that
the best anyway hope those questions
make sense thanks for doing the podcast
every week guys
goodbye goodbye i wouldn't like to do
ayahuasca around her
you would she's i just get good energy
yeah yeah
um uh
being around convenience is [ __ ]
hilarious i i don't mind
the thing the reason i don't go to roast
is because it's people that i'm not
friends with [ __ ] on me do you know
what i mean like
some of them yes it's not the ones i'm
friends with that i'm worried about it
yes okay again it's the ones i'm not
friends with right
taking a shot at me like like where
patrice
at the his last roast where he's like
who the [ __ ]
he was just kind of like what are you
talking about like
i don't [ __ ] who the [ __ ] are you i'm
gonna die right like what
that's the one thing about the roasts
that are little it's more fun when it's
just friends
yeah roasting yeah like if if if a bunch
of people that i'm
friends friends with want to make fun of
me yeah and also
the great thing about being friends with
great comedians is like
the per the most powerful microscope in
the world
looks at you and it's like
well it's like just [ __ ] funny yeah
like chappelle said the fun like a joke
that's
only funny to my family but it's from
dave so it's like a
priceless heirloom yes it's
you know what i mean like so that's the
[ __ ] or if like
the if i make fun of it's like if chris
makes if we like make fun of each other
it's [ __ ] oh that's great yeah it's
like ted williams
took a swing and hit my head with a
baseball bat
i'm on it's an honor yeah okay but some
bum some [ __ ] open mic
i'll kill you i'll [ __ ] kill you
right
um to be around no it's great
it's great also i know when
you have to also know how to play with
comedians some people
um it is one of a few ways some people
think they have to participate
you don't shut up and listen to funny
people
it's so easy to just be an audience
member some people feel like
oh yeah like you know we're not all here
like
they're so funny why would i interject
so i like
listening i like being part of the crowd
one it's just these great comedians
why i don't i don't have no desire to
speak up so some people kind of
get nervous or right or they want to get
their shot in that's what i'm saying
they feel like and it's like just no
dog why are you wasting this
exactly let it happen i mean i was one
time
uh i was working on a thing with miguel
nunez and it was miguel
eddie and arsenio
and me and my friend and i cannot
explain to you how funny it was it was
the funniest thing i've ever heard
and they were just roasting each other
like someone walked up and asked
a question and it was like an hour of
jokes
it was so funny yeah so um
yeah it's like why would i be like and
then one time
because people's natural inclination is
like i couldn't get a word in edgewise
well all right how good were the other
words
probably pretty good words pretty good
people like a paid these
arena acts
uh yeah and then some people walk away
being like that guy wasn't super
friendly
you were you being annoying and trying
to butt in right
or was he just all the same well also by
the way it's a private conversation
it is you're you happen to be privy too
but it's not about me and how i relate
in
i think when i walked with you and dave
around dc was
one of my most favorite uh moments
and i think when i ran into you guys in
the bay too
yeah you guys were just it just was
funny and fun and
the energy because you two know each
other so well the energy was easy
yeah so it's easy to just mix in if you
have the right disposition some people
bomb some people get nervous and
like you see famous people they're like
my cousin
worked on you know
whatever um
[Music]
yeah just be cool just be cool now i
will say comedians
not they can be a little selfish and not
a little something a lot of selfish
that's the downside that's the downside
of friendships with comedians
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah oh yeah it's
like if i'm going to the hardware store
for oranges
goodbye you've got mail you would date
this girl
hey neil bianca day one feeler here
i'm reaching out to you to see if i can
get some feedback about the current
situation that i
am in here in taipei taiwan
we are going through our first home
since the beginning of the
kovid pandemic and i
am a teacher here i'm not a teacher by
trade
i came here for a year to
see the world i love asian culture and
to experience something something
different also
i was running from the coveted pandemic
in the united states
before these past few weeks
coveted was relatively not even touched
right
here in this country everything was open
it was status quo
now we are in level three lockdown where
i am required to do zoom calls with my
students and it's something that i'm not
familiar with
not the most comfortable with in this
type of setting
i can do zoom calls with clients
adults but the best part about this was
teaching kids in person
and um that entire experience
so my question to you
is do i fail do i dip set and go back
to the us speaking nails language or
do i stick it out for the next six
months and finish out my contract
do i continue keep to keep running from
kovid
i would go on a date with her i also
liked her vocal pitch she has
nice it's she's a sexy voice and
very nice eyebrows that's a girl only
girls
but you are affected by them but i
noticed them yeah you're welcome
oh thank you i didn't know why i wanted
them yeah exactly
um it's also a testament to why
good-looking people
that question should have been half the
length
because she said it was because she was
like and you know it's funny
it's kind of cold in here you know what
i mean you know what i mean yeah
um she's very good-looking um she's very
cute
kylie jenner had to get a lot of surgery
to look like that yeah and she looks
better so yeah of course
um the better voice well she's my
girlfriend um
so uh she didn't explain i'm assuming
she's half taiwan
taiwanese um she ran
but you can't just run to taiwan they
weren't letting people in
well i don't know i think she's half
taiwanese
she probably is china calls it half
chinese
okay because they because they you know
why
um so
that's a tough one okay here's the deal
i'm gonna tell her
my friend who had to do one of my best
friends is a
fourth grade teacher in san francisco
and she had to do
all of this year uh remote and
it was really hard for teachers like she
was pretty depressed
uh she doesn't cry a lot and she it was
really hard and she
when it was safe enough at some point
when we were allowed out
or when they were allowed out in sf the
teachers got together and they just all
cried
yeah i believe it like they just drank
and cried yeah and it was
extremely hard to connect i think it's
just a lost year
so i feel like she should knuckle down
and
and stick with it she got a really good
deal
yeah you still even if you have to do
six months in taiwan
that's still a better deal than you
would have gotten here way better
so and you made a commitment and your
words gotta mean something
that's my girlfriend you're representing
both of us and
i don't want that reputation
dude how do we feel about dipset i mean
it made your heart go i didn't love it i
thought it was misappropriated
i don't think it was inappropriate i
thought it was misappropriated
interesting you only like it when
i've never heard it used i'm going to
dip i've never heard someone say i'm
i'm a dipstick she's like she's a she's
a youngin
[Music]
yeah but that doesn't mean just because
she's young doesn't mean
she knows that she's using dip set
correctly you would use it
you you use it i never said i'm gonna
dips no but you use similar things
bounce you said bounce earlier
yes intentionally
um oh and neil is
a wigger oh that's so good
um i don't know i just i don't know
i i think she should stick it out
because she's got a good deal so far
yeah agreed okay goodbye
you've got yours and bianca love the pod
so my question is so i uh last year i
moved back
from the bay area to my home in india
because i was laid off
during covered and i have lived in
america for eight years and it's been
hard to be back it kind of sucks
and i miss small and stupid things like
trader joe's and stuff
and how immigration is set up for us the
only way to come back
is to go for a phd
and i don't know if that's the right
decision considering
it's a lot of work and i'm already
pushing 30.
so yeah let me know if you think it's
worth the gamble
thanks love the show hey
um so you could come back to america but
she has to
she has to do a phd and she's been
studying this whole time and she's
almost 30.
yeah uh i just depends on how much you
miss it also phd is what two three years
changes is good i mean trader joe's is
pretty good
i think it depends do you wanna live
here
if you wanna live here then come back
because you know you never know what
happens in like two three years
um yeah i yes
come come back come on back i'm back
i mean it seems like you're already
she's
getting a masters probably so like
yeah what's another three years what's
under that
what's it hit it goodbye you've got mail
hey neil and bianca the difference
between whitney houston and demi lovato
is that whitney
actually tried to be artistic with her
music
demi lovato is not interesting because
they have no artistic value
this is why they're coming out as
non-binary is not
interesting and announcing it seems like
an attention grab
i would love to hear both of your
thoughts on the artistic
value of popular music today love the
podcast
thank you my point was that their
pr is being handled differently as drug
users
right yeah that i'm wasn't not
interested in demi lovato
inherently and by the way demi lovato as
i said on the podcast
has a [ __ ] incredible voice i like
some of her songs
and i if she i don't think pop songs
make something irredeemable
like i don't think it's like
automatically you're you're not serious
um because michael jackson made nothing
but pop songs and
was considered a real artist like who
was so just deangelo
no i think he's saying he's saying that
like
pop stars hurt she's more manufactured
and they had more i just i think the law
goes into all that [ __ ]
i don't know i i also don't think
whitney houston was
any more of an artist than demi lovato
yes she's a better artist
yeah she didn't write any of the songs
no does sami lovato write her songs no
no no one writes their songs
demi lovato might get she might be smart
enough to steal co-writing
um she has a team
she but she's had taken an active role
i'm sure whitney has
writing credit now she wrote i don't
think whitney
does but let's look it up this is like
when you're on a hit show long enough
you're like the ep
no that's right she wrote count on me
waiting to exhale and
[Music]
fine those are hits
co-wrote that's a stamina lovato again
yeah that's so and demi lovato
co-wrote how many but i think there's
how many song she wrote a lot i think
how many songs you wrote
uh i think the difference is though like
back when whitney was doing it
i think it was just kind of more like i
feel like celebrities are way more savvy
now like no
give me points put my name on it let me
get my cousin's name
you know they're just more yeah they
always go let me get my cousin on there
let me get my cousin
uh the
what happens is they take credit and no
points
i know a gigantic artist
singing artist who when
he or she is involved in writing a song
or singing a song
because by singing it by this person
singing it it makes it
it's not levine by the way in case
anyone's thinking um
like question in tv when someone's on a
hit show and then on the later seasons
they're
now you're exactly right no it's they
i'm a director
wow incredible that episode was actually
yeah you know someone i don't even want
to say hi
um yeah um so
so demi lovato is turns out sir
more of an artist than whitney houston
on paper so
well i mean she's less of a
of a a shell
you know what i mean she's not just
selling somebody else's word she's
writing her words
so sir you're at least wrong on one
count
what was his point again though that
demi lovato is not
as artistic as whitney houston no no
he's saying something about interesting
but they're we're not as interested in
them uh okay
but he's wrong i'm not interested in her
because i'm exhausted by it
which has nothing to do with her being
an artist
unless her art is exhausting
in which case she's the picasso
of exhausting me go ahead goodbye
you've got mail thank you for all these
readings
thank you for sending in audio and video
so much more interesting so
much so much better better so i'm
listening to your show
and you guys are on the question about
bianca always getting
complimented on her beauty rather than
like her intellect or her ability to
make a good argument or whatever
um and i think that
something that's getting lost here is
like
sure every to be clear everybody loves
both
everybody likes to be complimented on
what they look like everybody likes to
be complimented
on their you know intellect or whatever
or personality what have you um
but when you constantly
get complimented on one it sort of gives
away
what that person values about you
like bianca is gorgeous
of course um and i'm sure she like she
puts effort into that but she
also clearly puts a lot of effort into
making a good argument and communicating
her thoughts well
and like all of that
work and like stuff that's genuinely
impressive and like there's a giant
cobra behind her
chasing her that's that noise is anybody
noticing
that like and if you are why aren't you
commenting on that um
anyway i love your show
she's not saying anything i so what i'm
saying is
right but what i'm saying is i shower
do you know what i mean i put my almond
oils on you know how long that takes
takes 13 seconds i would like to be
it's it's this thing of like
i don't know why how how i don't even
think you feel that strongly that
aggrieved by it
no i feel exactly what i said which is
like
in a j i think of it as way more
like psychology just this is how neil
feel
i'm a woman i'm not saying anything like
i'm a woman i'm just saying that like
people it's a majority male listeners
people relate to me
how you relate to me like i think i'm
really respected
for my from my bidding uh
no i think people i i think you know
when there's the the dumb
fall guy on the podcast people relate to
that the fall guy like on idiot abroad
or
yeah just whatever we really you you
you absorb what we're giving you you
observe the dynamic we're giving you but
i don't think that
i yeah but the people say you're
beautiful i think
i don't think that's because mostly
people listen to the podcast so
no i'm not saying because you only like
put me up for my beauty i'm saying that
like i'm saying that a lot of people
come here
they don't for your opinion and then i'm
here to like make it gel
and um we work obviously i know you
respect me in my opinion but
i think it's it's just a lot of the
attention when they do have our
attention for the little bit of time
they do which is in an email or a video
or whatever
is geared towards you that's what i'm
saying i don't think yeah it's just the
beauty thing and like that's clearly
what they value about you
i don't think she's wrong i just i don't
think she's wrong either i just don't
see why it's
it's an agreement when you don't get
called said told you're smart but if i
don't get
told i'm pretty people are fine with it
well no but she's yeah because i'm i'm
thinking about fairness
meaning uh that my point was i don't
give a [ __ ] that no one says i'm hot
like i don't
i truly don't care um
one bead of sweat comes down revealing
the lie
just quietly all his his bronzer
one time me and mike sure were pitching
a movie
bombing okay it had been our third pitch
of the day
no and at one point i look over and
sure's
talking and i just see one beat of sweat
no or are you like
done i literally said in that pitch
we'll come back next year with something
else
like i cut it off i was like you know
what you're not buying it i'm seeing it
here
like why are we doing it um but this
isn't about comparing me to you this is
just about comparing it me to me like
is it fair to not i also think people do
say yo when bianca said this i totally
agree with her because blank or like
bianca made a good point here
they say it to you i just think i don't
know
i just think the general comment is neil
you're smart or funny and bianca you're
beautiful
and i don't think that doesn't mean i'm
not beautiful
and it doesn't mean you're not smart and
funny no it's not
it's not saying it i don't believe that
it's because no one thinks i'm
but no one you're never gonna get a
letter she's still fighting that fight
and for some reason i don't think she's
but i also don't think i love her
pettiness
she's not wrong if nothing else i love
you and she looked persian and she had
good skin did she look persian mm-hmm
i don't know if she was interesting let
us know if you're a person please call
that go for another walk with your dog
with a giant cobra penis
um anything else audio video okay very
good
goodbye now we read and i read
you've got i'm not binky i moved back to
my hometown about a year ago
a year and a half ago and a girl i knew
from high school called me out of the
blue
went for coffee and i immediately knew
it was going to be uh
it wasn't it wasn't going to be a sexual
relationship bianca you're so beautiful
we still kept in touch and she called me
on the phone about once a week
just to chat and it would be close to an
hour she is also chronically broke
she's just been asking me to give her
progressively more money
first it felt like i was just helping
out a friend but i recently looked back
at it and she asked me for about 10 of
my salary
for maybe the last four months um part
of it is because she's currently jobless
but i also
see a lot of professional personal
decisions she makes that i wouldn't make
and it annoys me that i'm sponsoring
that
uh i would feel more responsible for her
if i was at least [ __ ] her
what's the best way to move forward
please tell me how to how to kneel filio
and what
binky thinkerton that's really funny uh
i don't i think you're
you gotta get out of there no you've
gotta like wrong
i think you're getting played my my g
yeah you got a dip
set out of this situation you got a
scrim scram
uh you got a scram dog uh no i i run
just cut i just be like hey you know
right now i'm just not financially
able to take like give like
you know give this to you and take care
of my what i need to take care of
uh i'd love to continue friendship and
i'm here for like emotional support or
whatever i don't even have to say that
what will happen is she'll call you one
more time
and then she'll stop calling she'll be
offended there's a high
chance of of how dare you
yeah because she's a grifter and they
have to
um because sometimes people like
lie to themselves about what this
is and she you're right she'll tell him
how much she did for him it's like well
why would you offer if you were
you know i'm in this position and now
you're just gonna
you know it's like it's his now it's
the burden is tran the the
responsibilities on him now
it's almost like you know some guys uh
get stuck playing child support
even though they find out the kid's not
theirs yeah well that's legally
no i know legally i'm just saying that
it's like well you've been
helping yeah you can't just go
yeah this is yeah you're not good how
did he get in this position what
happened to you dog
10 of your salary is that pre-tax
how does she know what ten percent of
your salary no he did it he did the math
and said damn
i never met someone who was tithing to
someone at a personal level
um personal tithe um
[Music]
family ties a pive family tithe
[Music]
um friendly i want this
we gotta move on and hopefully we'll
think it'll kind of
um tithing the knot
we're getting close rc and lee been
catching up on the podcast and about a
year behind just listening white mcgraw
episode where neal took a shot at the
at the big lebowski paraphrase he said
it's got good characters and dialogue
but a bad story he's not wrong
but i would defend the story as one of
the best jokes in the movie
as a backdrop remember that the big
lebowski is an odd tribute to noir films
like the big sleep and a long goodbye
lebowski has elements of that genre a
kidnapping plot involving a trophy wife
being the centerpiece
with slowly unfolding aspects of the
story behind that story which ends up
being hustle
not an actual kidnapping but what i love
about the big lebowski is that
the actual plot is about a guy who has
inadvertently swept into this other
story
begins with the dude having his rug
stolen due to confusion over his
identity
and ends where he is no longer involved
in that story so in a way the big
lebowski is a movie about a guy trying
to untangle himself
from a different movie which is why it's
hilarious to me
that the movie ends once he's out of
that other story
in a normal movie he might have he we
might have seen the birth of his coming
child a celebratory scene
of the dude and walter winning the
bowling tournament et cetera but instead
of seeing that we just hear same l8 news
about
how these events might unfold so is this
a dumb story yeah i think you could say
this but that's what makes it so fun
anyway
thanks for everything you both you do
thanks for everything you do love you
both
um i he's i agree
i agree i promise you most viewers don't
view it this way
no no no this guy's uh he's a super
super seer
this guy's a real seer this guy sees
things people don't say
he's got 20 20.
he was on he went to the jay-z justin
timberlake 2020.
black tie suit and tie soon
stupid the best timberlake song only the
last 10 years is that one for
like trolls which one the one sounds
like mcdonald's
can't stop the feeling oh trolls i
thought that
was about trolling oh oh yeah what does
it go like
kiss up the feeling
[Music]
timberland do that justin timberlake oh
they said timbaland nope
i'm talking about justin's channel like
yeah that's a good one goodbye
deeply amused by this masturbation topic
that keeps circulating on the show and
the awareness that some folks have
a higher propensity for ejaculation than
their partner in my most recent
relationship we were
much more open and honest with each
other than any of my previous partners
because of that we came to an
understanding about each other's libidos
and how to reconcile that he masturbated
almost every day and that didn't stop
just because we were in a relationship
it's what he needed to do and who was i
to stop him
if we didn't have sex that day he would
masturbate yes it was sometimes annoying
when i'd wake up at 5am to him wanking
it
before the alarm went off which to me is
so disgusting that's disgusting it's
discussed everything about that's
disgusting especially
having an orgasm before noon and if
i was you don't have orgasms between 2
am
and noon you don't what's wrong with you
no
morning sex no good and like middle of
the night sex is like
who's this for okay neil no orgasms on
an empty stomach for kneel
please and if i was feeling a certain
way [ __ ] it i'd participate but that was
on my terms and i never felt any
pressure to get him off on a daily basis
which was something he needed to do we
broke up for two pretty big reasons one
i didn't want kids and he
had two from a previous marriage i
thought i could do it i knew it would be
difficult but [ __ ]
and two he said we didn't have sex
enough and that was
that it was harming self-esteem
admittedly our sex life declined
and i have a lot of factors i'd like to
blame um
but suffice to say by the end it wasn't
really working so
few questions for you neil would you
actually be comfortable masturbating
regularly with your partner around
and bianca this is a great question
would you be comfortable with your
partner frequently masturbating
not just privately in the shower hunched
over and ashamed
but in the bed next to you when you're
falling asleep
um yes what do you think
uh i don't care about the female
masturbation
how about i don't want to see it no no
that's i mean
it's fine uh it's almost
like it's like do you want someone
putting ikea furniture together
constantly
no you know they're really in their own
world can't talk to them it's a good
analogy because when i masturbate i do
unlay the blueprints on paper
do you want someone completely on their
phone
a lot of a lot of lug nuts if you know
what i mean
the thing the thing that my penis bends
perfectly at a right angle like the
small little wrench they give you
so there's a lot of um i
don't i have
i don't know i've
been in a situation where
it was obviously this is
not a good relationship and uh
the masturbating next to me was done
as a [ __ ] you um
this is not that's not funny well or fun
or nice it wasn't
after you rejected him or after it was
after like we were
clearly not going to have sex after a
situation right
like okay you can be a psycho
and then vigorously noisily
rudely masturbate like no so i don't
know i have ptsd guys
post make one up come on do it
there's no t that sounds like dick time
time diving
stroke stroke stupid
um what what about or have you been what
i'm not
in front of somebody i'm not
masturbating to somebody i think it's
kind of weird
it's prisony it just feels like oh
it's prison it's always a little [ __ ]
you
it's a little [ __ ] you but dude in the
shower i don't understand she's in the
shower
when i'm not around the masturbating
openly around each other but we're not
we don't have anything to do
like i'm making lunch and you're
masturbating on the couch
oh you're gonna while you make lunch
yeah i'm gonna because it's like a
protest
yeah so i don't it's uncomfortable um
goodbye protasturbation
ellen hi lscner well that's nice i'm a
mid-40s whiteman
and i've been dating my mid to early 20s
white girlfriend for a little under a
year she seemed very well put together
and
mentally healthy for the first few
months they always do sir but we
and then a load of trauma red flags were
unfurled upon me
this seems par for the course but what
concerns me is that for
some of the issues she doesn't see them
as issues for example her mom is a
straight narcissist
who seeks to control every aspect of her
life and says negative things about her
to perhaps
unintentionally keep her from thinking
she'd be okay on her own in the world
she basically sees no issue despite
admitting her mother's nagging her
caused her issues with bulimia
i have tried for a number of months to
get her to go to therapy and talk to a
professional
she's recently agreed to do so my
question is in her current state of
mental health
our relationship is poor and i cannot
see myself being happy in it however i
think the issues can be ameliorated
really nice word okay with therapy and
effort
on her part should i stay or should i go
also if i break up with her
how can i do it in a kind way can't help
but feel like if i were to break out
with her
i'd be giving up on her would you
compound some of the traumatic
experience she's had
with males in her past further she's a
great girl i do think a relationship
could work if she
if she saw some improvement however that
improvement is not guaranteed
go goodbye
yeah it's not your responsibility and
the improvement it just
ugh you're gonna be worn the [ __ ] out
when she's
functioning barely yeah you know when
she's
kind of coming up to where you need her
to be if she's at the edge where
you need her to be you're it's going to
be where you're out you're going to not
be attracted you're just going to
it's just too much yeah i think um
i i get the guilt
but have you had that kind of like
giving up on someone
yeah it always feels like giving up on
somebody i mean you don't want to give
up on somebody
you're invested in their health like
their growth and all that [ __ ]
uh it's you just have to
accept the collateral damage of like
this person's going to speak
ill of me but you also have to take an
account half the people that speak to
this person are going to think she's
[ __ ] batshit crazy right
so yeah go ahead and talk [ __ ] about me
and then keep talking right now not
gonna end with me
yeah to disprove that i like to disprove
that i'm a bad guy like you
keep talking you'll see like there's
people i've broken up with that
are bad relationships that i'm like yeah
i don't you don't have any credibility
so right i'm still out here
no it's yeah hi neil and wilbanks rstnle
i've recently learned that 30 of women
experience nocturnal emission
so it seems that some women also need
sex to the point where our bodies cause
us to have sex streams and orgasm
although i believe this is probably tied
to
routine if you're used to having this on
a regular basis and then stop your body
sort of acts as
an object in motion and is trying to
continue the routine i'm a woman in my
late 30s and i masturbate or have sex
pretty much every night
um i've found that if i don't i have
nocturnal orgasms
i'm fully on board for sex or
masturbation every night for both
parties
i've been with guys who have had dick
stuff uh side effects due to
medications and that added with
schedules and interest levels
we've always given each other the time
and space to masturbate when needed
we also know that neil's habit is once a
day but i am curious about binky's take
on female masturbation frequencies
since it's rarely discussed that you
really we're really learning more about
here like
well practices um you
both deserve the hiatus from pod but you
will be missed how about some best
of clip shows in the meantime not
usually a fan of those but i like the
idea of the series
of horse sound effects and neil laughing
he will
will you're got some work to do
you didn't even hit the sound um
but you have work to do for the clip
show uh
well what okay hunka i'll repeat the
question
wait well i don't even remember what the
question was wait what are you asking me
i just got home why are you doing this
what are we doing um
uh we have always we known all neil's
habits of once a day i'm curious about
bianca's take on female masturbation and
frequencies
um okay i'm not gonna fully speak on
that but i will say
i have always had nocturnal emissions
that's what she's telling us what is she
keeping secret
i have a funny story that when i i'm
signed up for
all these emails alert i gotta learn on
my phone for this [ __ ]
um it's always with
it's very my sex dreams are
weird i have very weird dreams one i
taste everything in my dream
okay no no that's not that has nothing
to do with the sex like
okay you ever had sex no i just mean i
taste chocolate doughnuts ice cream i
can remember
the taste of them when i wake up and i
have to go eat them interesting
um i oh every guy i've ever dated i
always have a dream
at some point that their body's made of
hot dog and i eat half their body okay
okay so
my dreams are strange at the any time
i've had a sex stream
a lot of time it's with strangers
that i had a weird interaction with
interesting
positive or negative kind of like not
positive yeah uh and a lot of times you
eat hot dog eat them
that's just for someone i love but uh
i it's 50 50 girls and guys even though
i'm
fully straight i have no interest in
like sex with women it's overrated
go ahead um so i've heard and
when i used to play soccer
it was always i would always have a
section about the girl that we were
the rival the rival the rival girl i
like that i like that as a motif
yeah it's my motif it's uh so i don't
know i don't know what's going on with
me
but it's interesting at least
tell me about it i built a podcast
empire around it
goodbye rl
i'm 21 year old neil looking
[ __ ] tall skinny white glasses
big nose we get it
so naturally my girlfriend is asian girl
you gotta walk walk it lightly talk it
recently we got into an argument about
white privilege i said the best
definition of white privilege is
quote it does not mean that your life is
easy but it doesn't mean that your race
isn't something that's a major that's
making your life harder
to try to explain this i said that a
black person that is a child of a rich
person probably has a better life
than a poor white person she disagreed
and made a republican-esque argument
that we shouldn't compare the hardships
of one group to another which is
logically incongruent with the argument
that i agree with
for the existence of white privilege am
i wrong about the definition of white
privilege
am i wrong to point out the difference
between the classism and racism despite
their
generally tight correlation and am i
wrong about the rich kid having an
easier life than the poor white kid
despite the race of each one
[ __ ] a long-ass letter thanks for
everything how does neeliophilio
and what are the goddess of colors level
of fondness
or blunder swinging about was that was i
am i the goddess of color
i guess i don't know what's happening
sure what i don't know
he he actually gave himself a swing and
a mess
in parentheses okay because what the
hell
um what
go uh i think that's a great definition
and
the same point it's white privilege
what if it's um who's more privileged
lebron james or a white guy in a
wheelchair
you know what i mean like or they're
it's this they just have different
mitigating yeah there's lots of
mitigating factors and also we don't
say when we're debating white privilege
or explaining to people
everyone has privilege that's what we're
only saying white pillage
there's hot girl privilege there's tall
white guy privilege
you know there is privilege when you are
i don't know everyone has something they
can get away with that another person
can't
right it's the first time in history
though that somebody a group has been
expected to
compensate for their privilege i don't
even know about con
com compensate this is literally it's
just a concept
that is blown making white people lose
their mind oh yeah but i think the
expectation is
and therefore respond you have privilege
so therefore you have to approach things
differently
right or honest but a lot of it is let's
say to because when we call themselves
privilege
forever like i'm from a privileged
background but now it's there's
expectations that come with it there's
expectations that come with it but the
first expectation is like do you get it
and it's
blowing people's minds literally does
not change a white person's life
at all to be like oh yeah you avoid some
you have white privilege
i the my only defense of it is
they it's headed in that direction it
feels like it is
but i think it is i think the expect i
don't think black people
care about making white people admit
they have privilege
it's not for no reason because like i
said white people go like i'm from a
privileged background
and there was no and therefore but now
there's a therefore like they would have
said
i mean or you're from an underprivileged
background but all of
most ev most what the only thing people
really want
is do you get why do you get why
blank is blank you have white privilege
so do you get why it's like this for me
it's most of it isn't asking like now
cough up five bucks would be
a lamp give me the money give me it's
like and we're talking to people the
people are losing their minds of people
with like
boats in arizona who are like that's
ridiculous yeah their life they're not
going to do anything that
i just it's just a concept to try to
explain something to somebody that
do you and do you like this definition
it's okay what would you like to see in
it
uh the definition again it does not mean
that your life is easy to have white
privilege but it does mean that your
race
isn't something that's making your life
harder yeah it's fine it works
but i do think to explain white
privilege to people
it's you don't benefit there's no
like i like think of things as a graph
your graph doesn't
go up there's plenty of poor white
people that
get treated like you know they're just
different than rich people different
than
people from like cut from a different
class so i think when you say privilege
built different just high cognitive
them cognitives race norman
to me it's like white privilege is
really good
coin termed for attention getting and a
really bad
term for understand white people
understanding i think we need to
combine them defund the white privilege
okay what does that look like you know
that looks like a studio apartment for
you
so never going to happen
it's too it's too it's too late for that
guys go after the go after the others
yeah not this come on i'm chillin
come on he's under the weather i'm under
the weather i got a cold
it's not now how privileged can i be i
have a cold
i barely have an immune system guys guys
guys all right well you want to speak in
white privilege
one of the great things about white
privilege is what you don't have to take
[ __ ]
from people and i'm going to share that
with you thank you my queen of color
blunder or whatever [ __ ] you call it
goddess of color
um yes thank you for coming thank you
for encouraging us to vacation it's
funny
yeah it's hilarious
[Music]
[Music]